plus de 5,4 millions de guinéens sont
appelés aujourd'hui à choisir leur
président un scrutin décisif qui
allaient dans un climat de tension après
des mois de contestation contre la
volonté d'alpha condé de briguer un
troisième mandat le président sortant
est au pouvoir depuis 2010 au total
douze candidats sont en lice mais parmi
eux se dégage deux mastodontes de la
politique guinéenne le président sortant
alpha condé 82 ans et l'ancien premier
ministre et chef de l'opposition cellou
dalein diallo âgé de 68 ans un premier
tour aux airs de duels car les deux
hommes s'étaient déjà affrontés lors des
deux dernières élections
l'opposant à l'actuel chef de l'état
avait d'ailleurs réussi à terminer en
tête du premier tour en 2010 deux
personnalités politiques que tout oppose
cellou dalein diallo au discours policé
assure qu'il est temps pour lui de
relever le pays
alpha condé est plus frontal estime
qu'aucun de ses adversaires net à la
hauteur alpha condé est un ancien à la
tête de la guinée depuis 2010 est hors
de question pour lui de céder son trône
et pour s'en donner les moyens le
président sortant a tout simplement
modifier la constitution afin de pouvoir
briguer un troisième mandat un
stratagème régulièrement observés dans
d'autres pays africains et non sans
conséquence politique puisqu'il a
provoqué de fortes tensions
dès le mois d'octobre 2010 9 la guinée
conakry connaît des manifestations de
grande ampleur une contestation
violemment réprimée des dizaines de
civils sont tués des centaines d'autres
sont blessées ou emprisonnées
elle les enjeux de ce scrutin
présidentiel sont importants pour cet
état de plus de 13 millions d'habitants
en effet le pays dispose de grandes
richesses naturelles avec des réserves
immenses de bauxite d'or de diamant de
faire ou de manganèse et des mines
largement sous exploitées et qui ne
profite pas à la population plus d'un
guinéen sur deux vit sous le seuil de
pauvreté avec moins d'un euro par jour
selon l'onu lors de leurs meetings
respectifs condé et diallo s'invectivent
chacun leur tour le challenger du
président se montre particulièrement
offensif
il estime que le président condé n'a
plus la capacité physique et
intellectuel d'exercer à 82 ans
diallo lui accuse également condé de
surfé sur la vague de l'ethnicité le
facteur des ethnies qui pourrait
justement faire basculer les votes les
malinké se reconnaissent dans le parti
d'alpha condé et les peules dans celui
de cellou dalein diallo
les deux groupes représenterait
largement plus de la moitié de la
population selon les experts
l'appartenance communautaire est
importante mais ne serait pas
déterminante dans cette élection